[Music]
thank you in many ways to me Google
cloud is a natural extension of our
mission to make information accessible
and useful we're just doing it for
businesses it means increasing the
availability and lowering the cost of
data storage and computing resources it
means making it easier for businesses to
understand and act on critical
information just to give you a preview
we've got Disney here we've got our
partner si P we've got Colgate Palmolive
we've got Verizon we've got Home Depot
we've got HSBC one of the world's
largest banks and then we'll close out
with eBay with a pretty wonderful demo
currently we have about 500 projects in
the cloud uh-huh that includes
everything from customer facing or gets
facing products and production makalah's
to dev QA to our R&D environments and
also all of our data suite review
running are running out of bigquery
today we are delighted to announce here
in San Francisco the general
availability of SAT HANA
on Google cloud platform in one weekend
in November we took more than 20,000
users live so all polled more than
28,000 users and six months
90 percent of our users are active on
Google Drive and in February alone we
had more than 57,000 hours of video
hangouts so I understand you're going to
start moving 150 towels and Verizon
workers what were you looking for so we
did a comprehensive trial of GE and our
employees really loved it they loved the
simplicity and intuitiveness of the
product the ease of use the real-time
collaboration really blew them away
thinking differently about resiliency
and availability moving from I think
what's a classical big company IT
orientation which is make the
infrastructure robust
to a more modern view that says just
assume that everything's going to fail
and that was a big catalyst for us to
engineer our software differently and
and partner with you guys on learning
what does it mean to live in a world
where you make your stuff resilient to
failure we're a bank at the core of our
business we're a bank but we also have a
significant technology company and
better within the organization and the
question that I was asking the
management team is you know do we really
want to compete with the cloud providers
and people like Google are we really
going to try and do what they do as well
as they do it in five months we went
from nothing to the entire 1 billion
live listings of eBay running in GCP it
was not a test
it was not a prototype it quickly moved
to a production great environment for us
that we ended up launching and bringing
in to market six months ahead of our
plan we've often considered videos the
dark matter of the digital universe
today I'm very excited to announce an
entirely new API powered by machine
intelligence the video intelligence API
what we need is a more scalable and
effective way to democratize data that's
why I'm thrilled to make the next
announcement Google Cloud acquisition of
taggle if you leave me and professor to
us we put 30 billion dollars and I know
because I approved it too it's real
right into this platform please do not
attempt to duplicate it you have better
uses of your money